昨天我們收到一個案例，讓我看了很有感覺。現在的孩子啊，每天拿著手機、平板，眼睛都快黏在螢幕上了。
嗯，這確實是現代父母普遍的焦慮。想讓孩子放下3C產品，但好像也很難找到什麼有趣的東西來取代。
對啊，所以我看到這個案例的時候，就覺得特別有意思。它是一個賣「懷舊童年嗜好」的生意，主打讓孩子遠離螢幕，結果今年的營收預計能達到一千兩百萬美元。
一千兩百萬美元！這數字確實很亮眼。在一個大家都覺得數位化才是主流、才會有大商機的時代，這樣回歸實體的產品，還能創造這麼高的營收，確實出乎意料。
真的，我一開始也覺得很訝異。現在創業好像就是要搭上AI、元宇宙這些科技浪潮才行，誰會想到賣這種「老派」的東西會這麼成功？
這點其實不容易做到。很多公司在做產品或服務時，會慣性地往「更快速」、「更便利」、「更智慧」的方向思考，因為這些似乎是時代趨勢。
但這個案例反而是逆向操作，它賣的不是科技感，而是某種情感連結和實體體驗。這讓它在眾多數位產品中，反而顯得獨特。
所以它具體是怎麼做到的呢？我看到原文提到，它瞄準的是一種「懷舊」的情感。
沒錯，關鍵在於它成功挖掘了「懷舊」這個點，並將它與「讓孩子遠離螢幕」的需求結合。他們做的可能不是單一產品，而是一整套體驗。
比如，它可能提供的是組裝模型、收藏卡片、或是戶外探索的工具包。這些東西都有一個共同點，就是需要動手、動腦，而且能創造獨特的實體互動。
我懂了，就像我們小時候玩的那種積木啊、拼圖，或是去野外抓昆蟲那樣。它不只賣商品，還賣的是一份親子共處、共同探索的時光。
可以這麼說。而且，它的成功不單是靠產品本身，更重要的是它觸動了父母希望孩子擁有「健康童年」的深層渴望。這種渴望的價值，可能遠超過單純的娛樂性。
簡單來說，他們可能不只提供了一個「嗜好」，更提供了一個「解決方案」來緩解現代父母的痛點。
如果我是創業者或主管，從這個案例裡可以學到什麼呢？感覺不只是要往高科技走才能成功。
對於創業者和主管來說，這個案例最大的啟發就是「逆向思考」的價值。當所有人都往一個方向擠的時候，你反其道而行，反而可能找到藍海。
重要的是，要深度觀察目標客群內心的真正需求。父母要的可能不只是讓孩子「沒事做」，而是讓孩子「有意義地玩」。
聽你這麼一說，我想到，這就好像大家都在追求效率、追求快的時候，有人反而去推廣「慢活」的理念，結果意外地受到歡迎。
沒錯。所以，不要被現有的主流趨勢所綁架，有時候退一步，從更本質的人性需求出發，反而能找到創新點。
另外，也要思考你的產品或服務，除了功能性之外，能否帶給消費者更高層次的情感價值或解決方案。
那對於一般上班族來說呢？這個概念能不能帶到我們日常的工作或生活裡？
畢竟我們不一定是在創業或當主管。
當然可以。在工作上，當你面對一個問題時，不妨試著換個角度，質疑一下大家習以為常的做法。
比如，當所有人都用數位工具開會時，你能不能試著組織一次「無螢幕」的腦力激盪，回歸最原始的紙筆，說不定能激發出不同的創意。
哦，這很有意思，有時候我們確實太依賴科技，反而限制了思維。
在生活上，也是一樣。當大家都在追求最新的電子產品、最快的網路速度時，你也可以試著找回一些簡單的樂趣。
比如說，週末放下手機，和家人一起去戶外走走，或是重拾一個你小時候喜歡的手作嗜好。這些可能更能帶給你身心上的滿足感。
我覺得這個案例最棒的地方，就是它提醒我們，有些時候，越是簡單、越是回歸本質的東西，反而擁有最強大的力量。
是的。在一個資訊爆炸、快速變遷的世界裡，能夠讓人慢下來、重新連結實體世界的東西，反而會顯得彌足珍貴。
所以，有時候，跳脫主流，反而能找到屬於自己的成功之路。今天的分享就到這裡，下次再跟大家聊聊其他有意思的案例。